les grandes manoeuvres oui probablement
slimane mais quand même ça fait partie
du quotidien de la vie parlementaire
d'un certain point de vue les grandes et
les petites manoeuvres
là nous avons un groupe socialiste
groupe socialiste il est lié à la fois
aux assises de l'assemblée nationale à
la fois au parti socialiste il est
dépositaire pour ceux qui ont été élus
aujourd'hui et peut-être aussi pour ce
qu'avait été lu auparavant d'un message
s'est occupé votre rôle soyez ce
pourquoi vous avez été élu et je ne me
suis pas fait élire jeter tête de liste
dans mon département
je ne suis pas fait élire en disant voté
pour moi pour que j'aille aider le
gouvernement d'édouard fini par mettre
en oeuvre une politique c'est que
parfois vous n'êtes pas avancer